hello and welcome to this video playing
respect I go okay who is that taaha
keyed off USSR rapper champion 1991 okay
so playing a classical open here and see
what he does two main things they're
ready or the Catalan yeah my dear three
on d4 other main options here okay I
think I'll take this
I think a six is right trying to keep
the pawn in some cases it's an always
slightly dangerous try to hold on to
this but it's often also an interesting
way to play
okay so b5 yeah it's there something
happening I don't know I think I can do
this Knight e5 there also is c6c 696
queen bee six returning a pawn but
speeding up my development might be a
droopy eight of the night goes back
somewhere I go Bishop e7 sometimes night
a5 is a move but 0k seven looks ok I
think Kate's speed up development here
ok um yeah just taking this on a song
maybe I wonder I wonder if it's a good
idea actually I don't think so let's
it's just develop stuff it shouldn't be
bad
the night only three is not particularly
great
it looks okay I'm also taking d for him
and I think it's this is for real I can
sometimes just take it there should be
three I can oh I can take you five maybe
d take c5 Quincy six check and then I'm
95 this doesn't look bad at all ok check
ok Knight g4 is that any good ever just
95 is fine he has a hard time to play em
to play you for here anyway like a blue
sugar to e4 I have note before 493 this
is pretty awkward and Bishop c5 is a
move maybe just Bishop c5
28
threatening some discoveries and that's
a pretty good position and I'm up on
time not too bad okay so taking it now
on yeah I'm taking it so what about this
he might attack you might attack here my
night I wonder i have c 3 as a move or
is that premature after Eva I don't want
to go back that that that looks I'd like
to play actively with my night
hmm c3 is an interesting okay i have to
have to play now afford a snide f4 check
takes root tea too
maybe maybe you can just take its III
but after Queen takes you five is
checked so it's technically problematic
yeah that's a pretty good position I
think yeah that looks looks good for
black also cannot into the night now and
II for there's still night afore check
so let's grab you five yeah this is
blundering the Queen Jay it was bad but
not that bad white resigns hmm I have
hard to say what went wrong yeah i think
the position was pretty good out of the
opening I like this I like this position
here after he captured and I don't know
it probably has to do that 95 you know
he's also spending lots of time here
with night here he hear back and in the
meantime my development is catching up
pretty quickly ok txt X and here there's
also Bishop takes a three what the
engine is giving just playing for that
see porn man it's not bad but I don't
think this is particularly bad either
that's already pretty good advantage
check they're just just very comfortable
let's see 228 21 mmm yeah black a
somewhat better but tough to say how
much ticks ticks and now that c3 move
it's the most forcing move one point is
that this is not working for rooty to
and I was thinking maybe just here and
then then we continue here I think
castles and well does this cannot be bad
for me but it's difficult to say how
good it is I probably can go around here
but that's not losing for white which
might be the case after the capture
again if force is not playable j and
galaxy one I grabbed the pawn which is
actually not what the engine wants to do
it wants to Castle hmm
yeah I mean okay you can cancel the e4
is still not chest wall and still that
move so but what I don't get is what is
the computer giving okay that is the
queen blonde of it it wants to do this
and now what I don't get is if I just go
back here why am I just why is that
something for Wyatt night before hmm he
gets that bag and night night and also
not good on f6 I have to go here and i
will seed
yeah yeah the computer still gives only
a slight edge for black nothing nothing
to grade castles yeah i'm somewhat more
active here and i have the slightest
safer king but it's nothing particularly
remarkable okay well so i'm pretty happy
with this game thanks for watching